JULIE WESTKIRCHEN: OK.
Welcome, everybody.
I'm Julie Westkirchen from
the Talks at Google team
here at Google LA.
And today is Take
Your Dogs to Work Day.
And we see a lot of dogs here
in the crowd which is great.
And we are excited to
welcome Seth Casteel.
Just a little
background on Seth.
In 2007, he began volunteering
to photograph homeless pets
to help them find
loving families.
And, since then, has developed
a career as a lifestyle pet
photographer
accepting commissions
and commercial
assignments, collaborating
with dozens of publishers,
and exhibiting his artwork
in galleries around the world.
His work has been published in
"National Geographic" magazine,
"The New York Times",
and in hundreds
of other magazines,
newspapers, and calendars.
His non-profit campaign,
One Picture Saves a Life,
inspires, empowers, and
educates Animal Ambassadors
around the world to improve the
image of rescue and adoption
through positive photography.
His book, "Underwater Dogs",
was the bestselling photography
book of 2012.
And today, he's going to
talk about his new book which
is called "Underwater Puppies".
So please join me in
welcoming Seth Casteel.
[APPLAUSE]
SETH CASTEEL: Thank you.
It's good to be here.
I actually live down the street.
I never had an opportunity
to come here to the campus.
So kind of exciting.
I was also up in the
Mountain View area yesterday
riding around on a Google bike.
So I've had two days of Google.
Pretty cool.
So my name's Seth.
My last name's Casteel.
I am an author sort of.
OK, I always tell
people I'm an author.
And they're like, well,
what are you writing about?
Nothing.
[LAUGHTER]
SETH CASTEEL: So I'm
technically an author.
But also a photographer.
But more than
anything else, I just
love dogs, and then cats, and
lots of other animals too.
So that's just kind of my thing.
A little fun fact about
me, I don't really
even love photography that much.
I'm not the crazy photography
guy a lot of people
think that I would be.
Years ago, I think I
just got real excited
about learning
about photography,
and the cameras, and the lenses.
And I used to bring my gear
everywhere, travel around
the country, around the world.
I'd take pictures
of everything--
my friends, myself, landscapes.
Anything I could just take
a picture of, I would.
And then, I think
I just realized
I was missing out on the moment
which I should be enjoying.
So it was all about the picture.
And I just missed out on
a lot of moments there.
So I stopped taking pictures.
Really, I don't take
pictures of anything
unless it's something
that I'm really
passionate about like
this project here.
I have hundreds of thousands of
pictures sitting on hard drive
from years ago some of
which might be pretty cool.
I haven't even looked at them.
Haven't even looked at them.
In terms of my
career, I might be
a photographer for
another few years.
I might.
I might not.
I have no idea.
I just like to use
photography to tell my story
and tell the story
of my subject matter.
And that's why I use photography
because it works out for me.
Before we get into
this, first of all,
how many dog people out there?
[LAUGHTER]
SETH CASTEEL: That's surprising.
OK, how many cat
people out there?
All righty.
[LAUGHTER]
SETH CASTEEL: I like cats too.
But I'm more of a dog guy.
Actually, I'm working on
the new book right now,
"Underwater Cats".
[LAUGHTER]
SETH CASTEEL: If you
go to the website,
Underwater Cats.com--
which I own-- you'll
find approximately
zero pictures.
[LAUGHTER]
SETH CASTEEL: That book
is on hold indefinitely.
But in case the world
turns upside down,
and dogs become cats,
and cats become dogs,
I will be ready for that moment.
Speaking of cats, this
is how I got started.
And I'd like to
speak to you guys
for maybe about 30 minutes-ish.
If people are disappearing
or throwing tomatoes at me,
I'll try to cut it off sooner.
But you give me a
microphone, and you give me
a huge screen like this,
I'm going to ramble on.
So also, at any
point during this,
if anybody has any
questions, feel
free to just raise your hand,
run over to the microphone,
and ask me.
And I'll do my
best to answer you.
So this is how it
all started for me.
I'm originally from
the state of Illinois.
I moved out to
California in 1999,
went to Chapman University
down in Orange County.
Studied film production.
Thought I was going to be
a movie director, a movie
producer, a movie writer.
Got a job at Sony Pictures,
right out of college,
as an assistant.
And then, moved into finance.
And actually, had quite
a bit of responsibility
in finance having no
experience in finance.
And people are
wondering why Sony
wasn't doing so well for awhile.
But made the transition over
to motion pictures where
I was working on
advertising campaigns,
movie posters, trailers, TV
spots for all of Columbia
Pictures movies-- "James Bond",
"Spiderman", "Angels & Demons",
"Da Vinci Code",
that kind of thing.
Pretty cool.
And that's where I met these
little cats, these baby cats.
I had a friend of
mine, wonderful lady,
all about animal welfare,
all about helping cats.
She's the kind of
person who can't say no.
You ask her if she can
help, hey, I found a cat.
Hey, can you just watch
my cat for awhile?
Can you take this
litter of kittens?
It's always a yes.
So I think maybe her heart,
sometimes, is a little bigger
than the logic of her mind.
For that, you can
applaud her, but also can
get someone in trouble.
When I first met her, she was
also working at Sony with me.
She had five cats.
And then, within a period of
time, she had about 60 cats.
And I said, "You
know, I don't know--"
I'm not going to mention
her name here just in case.
But sweet lady.
But I said, "I don't
know a lot about cats.
But I feel like that's at
least five too many cats."
[LAUGHTER]
SETH CASTEEL: So anyways,
we found these kittens
on the Sony picture studio lot.
Basically, what
was going on there
was a bunch of cats
living on the lot.
There was a feral cat colony.
And then, my friend and
some other people there Sony
would take care
of the feral cats,
make sure they're well-fed,
their health is all right.
Any new additions, they
would trap, spay or neuter,
and release them back
into the studio wild.
The cat's had it pretty good
there in the lot though.
I mean, things were going well,
hanging out with movie stars,
unlimited food options.
And they called
all their friends.
I mean, they just
got on the phone.
They called everybody.
So cats were just coming
into Sony left and right.
What happens when that happens?
Baby cats.
So they found these guys.
And my friend was
like, "Oh, no, Seth.
More cats, the babies, you
know I have to keep them.
What are we going to do?"
So I had just got a Rebel XT,
from Canon, and a Sigma 24-70
lens, was experimenting with
photography a little bit.
So I said, "Hey, let's take
some pictures of these clowns
and use the Sony email
network, blast out the shots,
and see if we can get some
attention right away."
Because I just knew that
the kittens needed help.
And my friend was
way in over her head.
So that's what we did.
We snuck into an
executive's office, actually
John Calley's
office at the time.
He was out for lunch.
And the kittens were
just climbing around
on the furniture.
Didn't know much
about photography.
Didn't know a lot about cats.
Just did these snapshots.
I like the claw
here on the couch.
It's my favorite.
So did these shots.
Used the Sony network,
which you're not
supposed to use the
Sony network for that.
But I was saying, "What
is Sony going to do?
Fire us for trying to
help homeless kittens?"
It's a great PR line.
Sony fires employees for
helping homeless kittens.
So anyways, blast out the shots.
All the kittens got
adopted in about 24 hours
which is pretty cool.
Here's another little fun shot.
Two weeks later, we
found some more kittens.
Did the same thing again.
The power of the photograph,
power of the internet.
Just really an exciting thing.
And this is just
a volunteer deal.
So I started volunteering at
the West LA Animal Shelter,
taking pictures of dogs and
cats to help increase adoptions.
I just wandered in there, and
said, "You guys need a hand?"
They said sure.
So that's what I did.
I'll do a little slide show here
of before and after pictures.
You guys get a sense
of what I was up to.
And this is how it
all started for me.
First with cats.
These are typical
intake shots you
might find at an animal shelter
as of several years ago.
Still today, if you hop onto a
public animal shelter website,
you might see a lot of
very negative images.
I'm not a fan of that.
Anybody out there has seen
the commercials, on TV,
with the sad music,
Sarah McLachlan?
And so raise your hand if
you've seen the commercials.
How many people
change the channel?
Let me see that.
OK.
Quite a few.
So I love the SPCA.
Terrific organization,
they're friends of mine.
But I have to challenge
their campaign.
So when you see
those commercials,
it's a fundraising campaign
and not an adoption campaign.
The money is a big part of it.
It does take money to run
such an extensive operation.
But I have to ask the
SPCA at what cost?
What kind of damage are you
doing to people out there?
The perception of the animal
shelter is so important.
And you're really not doing
any favors for traffic
to the animal shelter.
Because people see images, like
this, and the videos on TV.
And they don't want
to go down there.
They don't want
They don't want to bring
their kids down there.
And it's tough.
So we do this instead.
I think it's just
more uplifting.
It shows people that
the animals are great.
They can be your best friend.
They're not broken.
They're not dangerous.
They're just terrific.
And they just need a
little help from us.
That's all it is.
So we're doing
these kind of shots.
So I was traveling
around to-- here's Olive.
And when these dogs and cats
come into the animal shelter,
they're coming in from of
variety of circumstances,
most of which probably
aren't very positive.
They have no idea
what's going on.
They're not looking their best
or feeling the best at all.
And it's not the ideal time
to take their glamour shot,
basically, that's going
get them a new home.
Unfortunately,
that's what happens.
These are called ID shots.
So dogs and cats
enter the shelter.
Basically, they get all
the information down.
They take an ID
shot or an intake
shot mostly just to
keep track of who's who.
But an image, like
this, will go up
on the internet
and other places.
And this is the
only thing that's
going to, maybe, draw
attention to Olive here.
So not exactly doing
Olive any favors.
You do this instead.
And what we're finding
is people are actually
printing out these better
images and bringing them in.
And they're having a reaction
that's really positive.
And they weren't afraid
to come in anymore.
When they see these
pictures, it's like we're try
to use elements
of nature, better
lighting, personality
of the dogs and cats.
And we just saw a
huge difference.
Chubbs.
[LAUGHTER]
SETH CASTEEL: He's a
funny little guy, huh?
I like the bandana.
But of everything
else-- this is probably
the middle the night
sometime in September,
2011-- ominous boots, legs.
I mean this is not doing
this dog any favors at all.
Do this instead.
This is in Chicago.
So basically, I
started volunteering
at West LA, South LA.
Then, I was traveling around
to different animal shelters
all around the country,
just volunteering.
And then, I started teaching
workshops, on my own,
also to people who
were interested in how
to take better adoption photos.
Also traveled to Europe.
Did a bunch of workshops
in Europe and Australia
which was pretty cool.
But through the course
of doing all that,
I learned a lot
about the marketing
of rescue and adoption,
and how the image of it
is so important that it
needs to be more positive.
Little Min Pin
guy, kind of funny.
[CHUCKLES] Bailey, I
mean you wouldn't even
know what this dog looks like.
Also in Chicago.
When I started volunteering
in Chicago-- Chicago's
the third largest
city, by population,
in the United States.
They have one of the
largest animal shelters,
also in the United States, with
25,000 pets intake per year.
At the time, when
I came in, they
had really nobody
taking pictures
at all other than
the intake shots.
The shelter's in a
bad part of town.
It's more in the
South Side of Chicago.
Not a lot of people
even know about it.
And I'm thinking--
there's really
nobody volunteering
there at all.
I'm thinking how could this be?
Since Chicago's a good city.
I'm originally from Illinois.
Good city, good-hearted
people, animal lovers.
What's the disconnect?
People just didn't
know about the shelter.
Or if they did, they
were just so terrified
that they just didn't think
they could go in there.
So fortunately today,
things are improving
with Chicago and
many animal shelters.
And that people are learning
that it's not a bad place.
Also in Chicago, Wilma.
And this is really a standard
Chicago Animal Care Control
photo as of a few years ago.
This is going to be the ticket.
So we're doing that.
And I did all these, probably,
60 seconds for Wilma,
meet the next dog, take
a couple of minutes.
Here's Blake.
Couldn't really see what
Blake looks like right here.
And you have that.
[LAUGHTER]
SETH CASTEEL: That's
one of my favorites.
Now, there's a little
smoke and mirrors going on
because, sometimes, I'll offer
the dog a treat-- if they're
allowed to have a treat-- and
they're behaving a little bit.
And so as they're
chewing treats-- yeah,
you want a treat, don't you?
[LAUGHTER]
SETH CASTEEL: As they're chewing
treats, I'll take pictures.
It also works good for people.
If you give your friend a treat,
you take pictures of them,
get some funny shots.
So now, we'll get to this guy.
So while I was volunteering,
somebody asked me,
"Hey, could I hire you
to photograph my dog?"
It was actually a Mastiff.
And this is back in 2007.
I said, "Sure."
So I started a part-time gig as
a lifestyle pet photographer,
back in 2007, and just continued
to do that as I, basically,
received commission.
So I was volunteering.
I had a part-time gig,
was working at Sony.
I got recruited, went
over to Disney for awhile.
Had a quick six
months over there.
Came in, worked
pretty hard, ended up
getting fired mostly
for embezzling.
No, just kidding.
[LAUGHTER]
SETH CASTEEL: Just the wrong
place at the wrong time.
Always loved Disney Studios.
Big fan of the
movies growing up.
Still a big fan of Disney.
But I wasn't drinking
enough Kool-Aid.
And I think I just
walked into a situation
where I really just
couldn't figure it out.
But I was putting in
about 100 hours a week.
Came in one day.
And they said, you
know, you're out.
And didn't really give
me any good reasons why.
But didn't cry about it.
Maybe, I cried for a second.
Said, you know what?
No hard feelings.
Didn't burn any bridges.
And I've actually
been hired back
on, by Disney, to
work on some projects
since then which
is kind of cool.
But I decided I'm
at a crossroads.
Do I stay in advertising?
Or do I pursue my
photography full-time?
I decided on the latter.
And things weren't
going that well at first
because I just didn't
have enough business
to pay for the rent, pay
for the car insurance,
pay for the health
insurance, pay for a hot date
every now and again.
So I wasn't able to go out on
too many hot dates for a while.
But a company called
Groupon approached me.
Everybody familiar with Groupon?
Groupon approached me about
doing a deal together.
And I was so flattered.
And then, it occurred to
me Groupon was pretty much
approaching everybody
to do a deal.
[LAUGHTER]
SETH CASTEEL: I took the bait.
For $59, you could hire me.
I would come out to photograph
your pet, or you and your pet,
at your home or a
location of your choosing.
And there was supposed to be
a 10 mile radius of my home
which was here in
the West LA area.
It turned out to be
about 150 mile radius.
Because people were booking me
in Orange County, in Riverside,
at San Diego, Santa Barbara.
So out of the $59, I made a
whopping $29 per photo shoot.
Split it down the middle.
I thought I was pretty good
on negotiating that deal.
As it turned out, it
wasn't such a good deal.
When you factor in
all the driving,
the fuel costs, and then
you factor in my time,
I mean, I was losing
quite a bit of money.
First, I was like, wait.
How much-- I'm not
making any money.
How much am I actually losing?
But we did book about
30 Groupon shoots.
I did most of those.
Lost quite a bit of
money doing that.
And I was already in debt.
I think I had about, maybe, 45--
$50,000 in debt at the time.
Things we're looking
that optimistic in terms
of having a career.
[BARKING]
SETH CASTEEL: Hey, guys,
keep it down back there.
[LAUGHTER]
[BARKING]
SETH CASTEEL: Who
would have thought?
Dogs barking.
But here's my little knight
in shining armor right here.
Buster, the Cavalier
King Charles Spaniel,
show up at this
Groupon photo shoot.
All right.
[LAUGHTER]
SETH CASTEEL: Now,
just get settled.
Settle.
Fortunately, I'm very patient
when it comes to dogs.
This is a Groupon photo shoot.
I show up at Buster's house
in Orange County, California.
Show up.
Supposed to be an on-land shoot.
Buster, obviously,
had other ideas.
I did an interview
with "NBC Nightly News"
a couple weeks ago
with Brian Williams.
And they asked me if I had
any original shots of Buster
from back in 2010.
And I'm like, surely, I do.
So I went through
the old hard drive.
And I found some of these.
And it just made me laugh.
Because I haven't
seen these since 2010.
But this is the very
first photo shoot.
And that's the first
time I met Buster.
He's obviously already wet here.
He's already been in.
In the background is
Buster's human named Jane.
And Jane is saying, "You'd
better not do that."
And Buster's saying, you
know I'm going in there.
So basically, he
just kept jumping in.
I like he's looking
straight at the camera too.
It's kind of funny.
So she was kind
of upset about it
because she wanted some
nice dry land shots.
I thought it was hysterical.
And I just loved to see how
much he loved the water.
So I left.
Bought the little
point-and-shoot underwater
camera by Sony.
Came back.
Did a couple experimental
shots like this.
Didn't even know if I was
taking pictures or not.
It was kind of confusing.
But I was just pressing the
button and see what happens.
So then, you have here he
is coming in a little bit.
And then, you have that.
And that's the
original underwater dog
shot that I took in 2010.
I got home.
I saw that.
I said, "Holy smokes."
[LAUGHTER]
SETH CASTEEL: "What
is going on here?"
So, of course, I was so excited.
I sent it to Jane.
Oh, my God, Jane.
You're going to love this.
This is just unbelievable.
She's like, yeah,
yeah, that's fine.
But you didn't
get the dry shots.
So--
[LAUGHTER]
SETH CASTEEL:--I went back down.
I drove back down there.
Did some dry shots of Buster.
And she was very
happy about that.
And then, I just got
more curious about dogs
in the water.
What's going on?
What's going on
with the connection?
So I kept driving
down there more times
just to see this little guy.
Did some more shots of him.
Tried different
types of camera gear,
underwater camera bags,
different types of housings.
You name it, I
pretty much tried it.
Experimenting with lighting.
And, really, just trying
to understand what
was going on with this.
Here's this which
is now, actually,
it's a giant tattoo on my arm.
This is one of my
favorite shots.
People are like, wait a minute.
You have a tattoo of somebody
else's dog on your arm?
I'm like, yeah.
But it's only almost
my entire arm.
It's not my entire back.
But actually, I took this
with an underwater camera bag.
And you put your
camera in there.
And you seal it up.
Then, you're just thinking,
is this going to work?
But we ended up with this shot.
Didn't even know about this
until about a year later.
I was taking so many photos.
I didn't know what to look for.
And I went back through
my images and I ended up.
But I found this shot.
Now, it's become one
of my favorite pictures
which is why I put it on my arm.
But this little dog surely
changed my life the moment
he jumped in the pool.
And if I could buy
him a beer, I would.
But he has unlimited treats on
me for the rest of eternity.
Here we are in the
water together.
I don't know who ended up
getting the tennis ball here.
Looks like it's going
to be a close call.
Here we are.
I think he looks
very noble here.
But you can see the tattoo
and his little face.
But I still get to see
him from time to time.
He lives down in Orange County.
And whenever I see him,
it's just so much fun.
So got curious after Buster.
Who else likes the water?
Started photographing some other
dogs just around the LA area.
I bought a surf
housing by a company
called SPL Waterhousings.
And basically, they're
a shop out of San Diego.
They make a case
for your camera,
mostly for surfers, waves,
surfing, body boarding,
that kind of thing.
For me, it was a more
affordable option
than a full scuba housing.
So I bought that for a
few thousand dollars using
the last available credit
I had on my credit card.
So that was the end.
I couldn't afford
rent at the time.
And it's, obviously,
a clear choice.
When you don't have
any money left,
and you have 50 or
$55,000 in debt,
you have to go buy an underwater
camera housing immediately.
[LAUGHTER]
SETH CASTEEL: So
that's what I did.
A lot of my friends thought
I was taking crazy pills.
Maybe I was.
They kept telling me,
you got do weddings.
I'm like, weddings?
I'm not doing
weddings unless it's
two golden retrievers
getting married.
So made these pictures for
fun, all around the country.
This ended up in "National
Geographic" magazine,
Visions of Earth
in August, 2012.
That's kind of a
fun thing for me.
Always a dream to be a part
of "National Geographic",
in the actual magazine.
And it was the opening shot
for the Vision section.
So about 40 million
people saw that shot.
Pretty cool.
Just from "National
Geographic" alone.
This is a picture that ended
up changing my life in terms
of how the pictures
became popular.
So I made the series for fun
with that camera housing.
Put them on my website.
February 9, 2012 this image
becomes popular on reddit
and Google+.
Thanks, Google.
Start making the rounds.
And then, it went on other
social media outlets.
You name it, it was on there.
In the course of 24
hours, it's estimated
that around 100 million
people saw the shots.
That's quite a few
people I guess.
I didn't really know
what that all meant.
It was just a frenzy.
My website crashed.
I had to deal with Go Daddy.
But I was on a shared
server, limited bandwidth.
So we could only
track however many.
We had, I think, 175,000
to 200,000 hits a day.
And that all we
could really get.
So we don't really know.
But I like to think people
tried to get on my website.
They couldn't get on.
So what you can't
have, you want more.
So I think people, maybe,
got more curious about it.
Woke up to phone calls from
the media and everybody else
asking about the pictures.
And my life has never
been the same since then.
On the phone with "CNN World
Report" with Anna Coren,
on the other line
"Good Morning America",
and trying to figure out
who's more important.
[LAUGHTER]
SETH CASTEEL: Good
problem to have.
But as somebody who was a
struggling photographer,
and who had zero
dollars left, I'm like,
I got to seize the moment.
This is an opportunity
here I think.
Seize the moment.
So we did.
I did every interview I could.
I just worked my tail off.
And made a book called
"Underwater Dogs".
Got a book deal with
a company called
Little, Brown and Company.
Chose an agent first.
Didn't know how anything
worked with book publishing.
Had no idea about the process.
Didn't even know all
the major players
in the world of publishing.
But I selected a lady
named Michelle Tessler,
out of New York, to be my agent.
She liked dogs.
I like dogs.
Seemed like a pretty good fit.
We made a proposal.
The book went auction.
And every major publisher
bid on the rights
to sell the book which
was kind of crazy.
And we ended up
choosing Little, Brown
and turning down Random House.
Again, kind of a
good problem to have.
But all this was
happening so fast,
I just didn't even realize.
I thought we were going to
get an advance of like $500
to make the book.
And I'm like, wow.
And then, we got a
little more than that.
So we threw a
party in Las Vegas.
[LAUGHTER]
SETH CASTEEL: That
was kind of fun.
The book came out
in October of 2012
with a very limited print run.
I was a first-time author.
Even though Little, Brown
was very enthusiastic
about the book, they didn't
print very many copies.
I didn't know that.
So basically, the book came out.
It was one of Oprah's
favorite books of the year.
We had a ton of media
around the book, of course.
And you couldn't buy
it, really, anywhere.
So-- I know.
I was like, I couldn't
buy my own book
for three weeks anywhere.
Couldn't buy it.
It was sold out everywhere.
I mean, I guess that's
a good problem to have.
But we were trying
to sell books.
So if you're trying
to sell books,
I guess you have to have books.
Regardless, it was still a
"New York Times" bestseller
for 11 weeks on the
hardcover non-fiction list.
It even beat out Bill O'Reilly.
Sorry, Bill.
[LAUGHTER]
SETH CASTEEL: [CHUCKLES] It was
the best selling photography
book of the year and one of the
best-selling photography books,
in history, with over a half
a million copies in print,
13 additions around the world.
And it's just dogs jumping
into swimming pools.
I don't know.
The craziest thing.
So anyways, it's a lot of fun.
Some of the adults thought
the images were, maybe,
too fierce, too
primal, too many teeth.
But all the kids,
that I was talking to,
just thought they
were hilarious.
So anyways, we made a
kids' book for adults.
So you can pick that
up if you're an adult.
If you're a kid, you
probably don't like it.
But if you're an adult,
you might really like it.
And you get a free poster.
So this came out
about a year ago.
And it's done well.
Scholastic picked up a lot of
copies for all the book fairs
around at the schools.
I remember going up as a
kid, you had the book fair.
And it was so exciting
to go to the book fair.
And you get to pick out
your book or a couple books.
So that's been fun that this
has been in all the book fairs.
And I wrote this.
Actually, I did do a
little writing here.
There's some fun
rhymes going on,
in the pages, if you
flip through this book.
And the publisher's like, oh,
we'll hire somebody to do that.
And I'm like, what
I can't do it?
So I wrote it.
I think it's kind of fun.
I don't know if it's good.
But it works.
We also made some
board books for kids.
Some kids were
ripping the pages out.
They didn't like the
kids' book because there's
no teethy images.
So they were ripping the
pages there were so upset.
So we made two board books,
"Colors" and "Numbers".
I recommend, if you're
learning to count to 10,
the book on the right.
It's a good one for you.
So that was kind of
cool to have those.
And then, of course,
the next project.
What do you do?
I've worked with dogs.
It's been great.
We made the kids books.
Obviously, the cat's thing
about underwater cats,
explored that for a second.
Shut the window on that one.
Although.
I have been swimming with
quite a few cats surprisingly.
So most cat breeds,
as we know, do not
have a history with the water or
an appreciation for the water.
It just doesn't exist
with some exceptions.
Turkish Vans, and Maine
Coons, as well as Bengals,
and some exotic mixes do
have history with water
and, actually, get in and swim.
Pretty cool.
And then, you talk about
exotic cats, wild cats.
You have tigers.
You have fishing cats
in Southeast Asia.
Even bobcats, you have
that kind of stuff.
That's definitely possible.
I've been in the
pool with tigers.
pool with bobcats.
Pretty interesting stuff.
But could you really make
a whole book out of it?
Questionable.
So we put that on hold.
Puppies.
So I'm like, well, I don't know.
Can I make a whole
book about puppies?
We have two puppies
in "Underwater Dogs",
the original book.
One is 12 weeks.
One is six months.
And I'm thinking, well,
these guys were into it.
Maybe we can do a book.
So started meeting up with
some puppies at the pool.
And figured out that not
only could I make it,
but it really needed to
be made for two reasons.
Number one, water
safety for pets--
this is the big message about
this project right here.
People don't realize that's a
huge problem here in the United
States.
Especially, swimming
pools are on the rise.
Global warming's happening.
It's getting hotter and hotter.
Swimming pools are
going up, especially
states like California,
Arizona, Texas, and Florida.
It's ridiculous.
Between-- and this is
a really sour stat.
But I'll tell you.
Because most people
don't think about this.
Between seven and 10,000
dogs drown in swimming pools
every year in the United States.
That's a lot of dogs.
And I feel like that
shouldn't be that.
It shouldn't be
one dog drowning.
And it's mostly
because the dogs don't
know how to get out
of the swimming pool.
That's it.
It's not because the
people hate their dog's.
people are trying
to set up their
dog for disaster.
They just don't think about it.
And I ask people, would you let
your 18-month-old human child
stay outside, in your backyard,
with your pool, unattended
while you're off to
work for eight hours?
And they were like, no.
Well, a lot of people let their
dogs do that or have access
to the backyard, where their
pool is, during the day
and thinking, oh, they're
not going to get in there.
But it happens between seven
and 10,000 times every year.
And I think it's just
absolutely unnecessary.
All puppies know how to
swim from the time they're
three or four weeks old.
You put them over the water.
And they will just do this.
And then, they will do this.
And then, they'll go faster.
And you put them in.
And they will swim around.
And they'll do a great job.
But they need to practice.
They need to understand their
physicality in the water.
And they need to
understand buoyancy.
Most importantly, they
need to understand
how to get out of
the swimming pool.
Not a natural body of
water, it's not a lake,
not a stream, not the ocean.
So dogs know how to swim.
But they don't understand the
concept of the swimming pool.
I do meet a lot of dogs who
like natural bodies of water.
And they look at the pool.
And they're like, what is that?
But once they figure it
out, it's all good then.
But you have to make sure
these little guys know
how to get out of a pool.
That's the big message with
this is preparing them in case
there's some sort of situation
where they find themselves
in the water.
So if a dog falls in, a
lot of times their instinct
is to try to get out
where they got in.
Dogs are not great
climbers, most of them.
Some Jack Russell
Terriers maybe.
But, in general,
they can't climb out.
So they will just swim
around, swim around.
Most dogs drown two feet
away from the stairs
or from the ladder.
And that's not cool.
So I'm trying to fight that
is what I'm trying to do.
I'm trying to let people know
that let's be safe about this.
Let's try to stop these
accidents from happening.
They're unnecessary.
It's just about education.
Be responsible.
In addition to
teaching your pets how
to get out of the pool,
it's also important
all the classic safety
precautions including--
look at this guy on
his back down here.
[LAUGHTER]
SETH CASTEEL: Limited access
to the pool, alarms, fences,
all that stuff also
really, really important.
I went on a mission.
I, basically, taught
1,500 puppies how to swim,
how to get out of the pool.
We practiced.
Travelled around the country.
And most of the puppies
who came out and just got
swimming lessons A to B,
start to condition them
on what are we doing here?
What is this?
And you, basically, teach
them where the exit is.
Now, once they start
with that state of mind,
they're like, oh, OK.
There is only one
way to get out here.
That's a good start.
But for sure, all the
humans that I met, I said,
"If your dog's ever going
to be around a pool,
you need to apply this
to that situation too."
But even still, as long as
the dog starts to understand,
I'm in a body of water, and
there's only one way out,
that's a huge
advantage for them.
Otherwise, they
just wouldn't know.
They just swim around in a
circle or stay in the same spot
the whole time.
They would have no clue.
So zooming around, mostly
didn't even take pictures.
I was mostly just a swim
teacher for about four months.
Zooming around, working with
all these puppies from six weeks
to six months.
Out of 1,500 puppies
that I worked with,
there's 72 in the
book and 105 photos.
So there's a lot of disappointed
puppy parents out there
who didn't get a great picture.
But at least the puppies
are going to be safer.
I also worked with,
mostly, rescue puppies
for this project.
I love dogs of all types.
I support dogs of all types,
all sorts, all backgrounds.
But I'm also a big fan
of rescue and adoption,
and always encourage people,
if they can, consider adoption.
Because it's terrific.
So most of these guys are
going to be rescue puppies
from different organizations
across the country.
Some tiny little rescue groups
and some major animal shelters.
And I decide this could be
a good reminder for folks
that adoption is a
great option for sure.
This is Popsicle.
This is in Chicago.
This is Ginger.
This was, maybe, going
to be the book cover.
But we thought, maybe it's
a little bit too sassy.
[LAUGHTER]
SETH CASTEEL: But one
of my favorite shots--
for any photography
buffs out there?
Anybody do photography?
Couple folks.
So if anybody's curious
about this, so this is I'm
shooting with a dive housing now
by Ikelite Underwater Systems.
It's a Canon 5D Mark III.
And this is probably the
least interesting part
of this, the technical stuff.
It's like, I just like the dogs.
But it's a 5D Mark III by Canon.
It's a fisheye lens, 8-15.
I'm using, yeah, the casing,
the underwater housing.
I'm using two DS161 strobes.
One here.
And the background,
that's not a pool light.
That's actually an off
board strobe or slave light
if you do any studio stuff.
So it's really cool.
It's a little gizmo
that you can't really
buy anymore because
it's off the market.
But I have some.
Always got to be one step ahead
with photography, I guess.
But these are pretty cool.
So I can drop them
into the pool.
It's, basically, a
strobe like this.
I attach a little
funny gadget to it
called an EV Manual Controller.
It's, basically, an eyeball.
You guys are
technical people here.
It's a little eyeball.
And it's got an optic
sensor in there.
So what it looks for
is a significant change
in ambient light.
When that little sensor
sees my strobes off,
it'll go ahead and fire
off that strobe down there.
It would be impossible
to try to wire
10 strobes in that pool and,
also, a little bit dangerous,
I think.
The puppies are jumping in.
I'm all over the place.
So I, basically, just
drop these in the pool.
And it helps to create better
lighting, and catch lights,
and it's just fun.
So when you're flipping
through the book,
you might think
they're pool lights.
But they're actually
called off board strobes.
And they're about
$1,700 a piece.
Sometimes, I'd have 10
of them in the water.
And you're looking at 17,000.
Plus, my camera's about 14,000.
So you got $31,000 in the pool.
And I don't even have insurance.
But I need to get some.
[LAUGHTER]
SETH CASTEEL: This is Raleigh.
This is in Tucson, Arizona.
Quick note about
this one, it was
important to work with the
puppies in really warm water.
Just like our human children,
teaching them to swim,
I don't think we're going to
put them in 40 degree water.
It might be a little chilly.
So we want to make sure the
puppies are comfortable,
have a really
positive experience.
And between 80 and 92 is kind
of a sweet spot for these guys.
This pool was in Tucson,
Arizona last September.
And I knew it was getting
kind of late, or kind
of cold at night,
like 40 degrees.
So I call the pool owner.
And I'm thinking,
I don't know what
the water's going to be like.
So I ask him.
And he's like, "It's cold."
"Do you have a heater?"
"Yep." "Can you turn it on?"
Turns it on.
I arrive the next day.
It's 100 degrees outside.
And the heater's still on.
I'm like, oh.
And the bubble tarp is on.
So it's locking all the heat in.
So we peel that back, 107.
Oh, too hot.
And so these little
puppies, you don't
want to put them in
107 degree water.
They can only be in there
for a couple minutes.
Went to the freezer, grabbed
some ice cubes, tossed them in,
didn't make a lot
of a difference.
Got to try something.
But the air temperature
started going down.
And then, the puppies arrived
later in the afternoon.
We got the water
down to about 102.
And we were able to
have, maybe, five minutes
of each puppy in the water.
Most of them, again,
just got their lessons.
And that was it.
But a couple of them jumped in.
So kind of a fun note.
These are my little
Terrier guys.
And this is also in Chicago.
Had a good, really good day
at Chicago for this shoot.
My first Chicago shoot,
we had 30 puppies.
I flew in.
I brought all my gear.
My gear didn't arrive.
Who knows where it went.
It just disappeared.
So I called a friend
of mine, shipped
in the back up gear
for another $400.
Planned this all out for weeks.
Went to the photo shoot, didn't
get a single book picture.
And that happened quite a
few times making this book.
I mean, if you think
about 1,500 puppies,
there's only 72
that are in here.
Most of them just didn't
even get pictures at all.
But then, we had another shoot
in Chicago at an indoor pool.
And we probably have 10
pictures from that shoot.
So we just never really know.
But these guys are cool.
We were going to make
it a two-page spread.
But then, we thought,
no, you know,
people are going to
think it's either
two different pictures
or the same dog.
And it's, actually, two
separate dogs that are siblings.
And I just think for
them to jump in together
like that, at the same
time, it's a rare thing.
So as we're doing our swimming
lessons, I have to gauge
are these puppies really
starting to be playful
or are they just
getting their lesson?
I don't want to push it too
much with these puppies.
It's important
that it's positive.
And that's it.
Some of these puppies
start playing around,
I grab my camera off the
side and wait for the moment
where they're jumping in.
Some of them are jump in
just because it's fun.
Or they'll jump in with me.
If you look at some
videos on my website,
you'll see me jumping in
together with the puppies.
And they'll come
in too, with me.
Some are chasing
toys underwater.
And some are diving as deep as
five feet, even at 11 weeks.
This is little Ava.
Ava's was a Beagle
mix also in Chicago.
And at six weeks, just really
impressive form and cute little
face with that
little white stripe.
And there's Ava all grown up.
The owners of Ava sent me
this picture the other day.
There's six weeks.
There's about a
year and six weeks.
But they grow up so fast.
They grow up so fast.
And just so proud to see them.
I've been traveling
around the country.
And I'd see a lot of these
puppy's now that are grown up.
And give them a big hug.
But it's funny to see
how they've turned out.
This is Cory.
This is also in Tucson
in an 80 degree pool.
Just really like this.
Love the color of the water.
Cory was terrific and one of
six Cattle Dog mix puppies
in Tucson-- all rescue puppies.
You also have Zelda.
This is my favorite
picture in the book.
It's not the most impressive.
It's not even underwater.
It's what you would
call an over under shot.
The reason why I like this
picture is this picture
embodies the entire spirit and
message of why I made the book.
And that's because little Zelda
here, at about seven weeks,
special needs puppy.
Needed some additional TLC.
And the human
caretakers for Zelda
said, she is not ready
to go swimming yet.
She's too little.
We're too worried about her.
And I was saying, well, I
think it's even more important
that she starts to learn.
Because she's around
a swimming pool.
You guys let her around the
swimming pool every day.
She's just running around here.
And she's probably
going to be adopted
by somebody who
has a swimming pool
or has access to
a swimming pool.
They said, no, no.
She's too little.
So she sat there.
And she watched her brother
and her other siblings
do swimming lessons.
For about a half hour, she
just watched, just watched,
just sitting there, watched.
Then all of a sudden, splash.
She jumped in on her own.
Jumped in.
I was on the other
side of the pool.
But she had been watching
us for a half hour.
And she watched
where the exit was,
watched where the stairs were.
She didn't swim to me.
She swam to the exit.
And she got out on her own.
This little tiny thing,
jumped in, swam over there,
and got out on her own.
And I was so proud
of that little puppy.
That was my proudest
moment of making
the entire book is this
little character right here.
Because that's what
it's all about.
And her humans didn't
want her to do it.
And she said, I'm
going to do it anyways.
So pretty cool.
Here she is on her little
surfboard. [CHUCKLES]
This is Monty.
This is sort of
reminds me of the movie
"The Ring" a little bit.
[LAUGHTER]
SETH CASTEEL: This
is at a dog pool
in New York called
Water for Dogs.
People don't know it.
But there is a swimming
pool for dogs in New York.
It's a hydrotherapy pool.
So this pool is mostly
working with dogs
that are restoring
quality of life
to dogs through
swimming, rehabilitating
from injury, and also as
alternative to surgery.
But hydrotherapy,
amazing thing for dogs.
And it really does
improve their quality
of life, when they have
certain situations come along,
and also extend their lives
sometimes by many years.
So if your dog's ever have
some troubles, some health
troubles-- depending
on what that
is-- look into hydrotherapy.
Because it can really
make a huge difference
for your family.
So they also, at
this pool, apparently
do underwater
puppy photo shoots.
So we did that.
And this is Monty at six months.
Doesn't really look
like a puppy anymore.
Still puppy mentality.
But I just think this
picture is fascinating.
I like to have different
types of images in the books
that I'm making.
And I think that my
whole thing with dogs
is I love their
range of emotion.
I think it's very
similar to human beings.
I think that's why we connect
with them in so many ways.
And I think that's why we
identify with the pictures too.
Because, I think, when we see a
picture like this, or smiling,
or doing whatever, we sort
of see a little piece of us
in that picture too.
But I love this shot.
Chinese and hairy, hairless.
A lot of people argue with me,
oh, only Labs and Golden's like
the water, in
Newfoundlands sometimes.
And I say that's just not true.
I've met quite a few Labs
and Golden Retrievers
that just don't like to swim.
Or they do get in, and
they're terrible swimmers.
Because they haven't had
the right experience.
So it's fun to be able to
profile some different types
of dogs, like the
Chinese Crested here.
At 10 weeks, little scooters
jumping in and having a blast.
Kind of weird looking dogs.
But, yeah, their fun.
This is Prince,
also excellent form.
This is in Portland, Maine.
Did an outdoor shoot that
day in about 82 degree water.
And at eight weeks, I mean,
this is just a natural.
This is a natural swimmer.
These are my Labs.
These are my stars.
This is down in
Fort Myers, Florida.
There's three of
them down there.
Reason, Grits, and Jack, they're
all from the same litter.
They're all being
groomed to be dockdogs.
Anybody familiar with dockdogs?
It's basically a
competition for dogs.
The idea is you have a
huge ramp, giant pool.
Which dog can jump the farthest?
And they also have
a new contest,
which dog can jump the highest?
So you have both of those.
The dogs go crazy for it.
The people doing dockdogs are
a little strange, I think.
[LAUGHTER]
SETH CASTEEL: They're
stage moms a little bit.
And they're all like-- But
it is a very positive thing.
And the dogs just,
they go crazy for it.
So at six weeks, they'd
started swimming.
By nine weeks, they were
showing up at the pool
and whining to get in.
And when I met them at 10
weeks, it was just a home run.
They were ready
to rock and roll.
They hadn't really
been underwater yet.
But it was just a no-brainer.
So they were just
happy to participate.
There they are,
little puppy teeth.
These guys, so I wanted to
try to have all three of them
in the same picture.
It was impossible
because of the hierarchy.
So how many of you guys have
more than one dog at home?
OK.
So you could tell
me that somebody's
going to be the
boss, somebody's not.
It's called alpha omega.
So dogs are pack animals.
Somebody's always
going to be the boss.
It may be very extreme.
Or it may be more subtle.
But there's always going to
be somebody who's in charge.
Even with these guys, even
though their living with three
separate people, they
spent enough time
together where they
developed a hierarchy.
So even if these guys,
who had never met,
they hang out for enough hours,
they're going to figure out.
It might even happen right away.
Who's the boss?
It might take a few hours,
or a few days, or a few weeks
to figure it out.
And they may challenge
each other for it.
These guys were trying
to figure it out.
Little Jack, who you
don't see in this picture,
Jack is somewhere
in the background
looking for another toy.
He decided, I'm not the boss.
So he's just doing
his own thing.
He wouldn't compete
with these two.
These two would compete.
And they were trying to
figure out who's the boss.
And that's why I could
get this picture.
I don't know who
the boss is now.
But I'm going to see
them in a couple weeks.
I'll be curious to
see who's number one.
But pretty unbelievable
to see these little guys.
If you hop on my
website, you'll see
some behind-the-scenes
video of them
swimming underwater
in slow motion.
And it's spectacular to
see what they're doing.
Here's a behind-the-scenes
still of me.
And this is either
Reason or Grits.
I can't tell by the collar.
But this is to show you
this is taken with a GoPro.
GoPro, this is a
HERO Black Edition.
I think this is
the 3, the model 3.
And did some behind-the-scenes
stills and videos.
You don't quite have the
illumination on me or the dog
that you'd might want to have.
But it's cool to see
the positioning here.
I'm holding my breath
and going under.
A lot of people think I'm
wearing scuba diving gear.
I said, "If the dogs
wear scuba diving gear,
then I'll wear
scuba diving gear.
But if the dogs
aren't then I'm not."
So we, basically, just go
down, come back up together.
"Underwater Dogs", I'd hold
my breath up to 90 seconds
to do multiple takes.
This book right
here with puppies,
I'm mostly underwater for
a few seconds at a time.
And that's about it.
The Labs, maybe up to
10 seconds, 15 seconds.
But there's really no reason
for me to have diving gear.
I do wear a wetsuit because
of the water temperature,
even in 80 degrees.
Anybody a scuba diver out there?
Maybe.
Scuba divers?
So if we're 98.6 degrees
unless you have a fever,
or you're an alien--
and then, you're
going to be I don't
know what temperature--
but if you're in water that's
80 degrees for a long period
of time, your core
temperature will drop down.
And you will get hypothermia.
And you don't want hypothermia.
It's no fun.
So even in 80 degrees,
you can get hypothermia.
I spend, sometimes, 14
hours in the pool in a day.
And if I didn't have
that wetsuit on,
I'm in 80 degree water,
and then sometimes I'm
just not moving
around that much,
my core temperature will drop.
And I will get hypothermia.
And then, it's just dangerous.
Never really a
life-threatening thing for me.
But it is something you
got to look out for.
So that's why I
wear the wetsuit.
And then, I also wear the
wetsuit because the dogs,
they have their claws.
They're trying to give me a hug.
They're really close
to me, sometimes
inches away from the camera.
And so, over time, you
get pretty scratched up,
pretty dinged up.
So I wear the
wetsuit for that too.
Here's about the same moment,
maybe taken a couple seconds
after this.
So here's this.
The tennis ball dropped
out of the frame.
In the book, you'll
see some tennis balls.
And also you'll see no tennis
balls in other pictures.
It just depends.
Sometimes the puppies
were just jumping in
because they thought it's fun.
Sometimes they're chasing a toy
like they're doing right here.
I try to sync to tennis
ball so that it's not always
in the picture.
I just don't like having a
tennis ball always in there.
I think it gets-- it's fun.
But it gets, also, a
little bit old too.
But you can see the
illumination in the puppy teeth.
That's not a dog or cat.
That's baby Kiera.
So this is my most
recent project
which'll be published in April.
I'm not baby guy.
I am a dog guy, and
then cats, and then
a hundred other creatures,
and then, maybe, babies.
[LAUGHTER]
SETH CASTEEL: No
offense to any parents
out there of human children.
But through the course of
working with the puppies,
I was just shocked at the stats
on the water safety for pets.
Same applies for human babies.
Drowning is the number one
cause of accidental death
in children, under five,
in the United States.
Between 500 and 700 children,
under the age of five,
drown mostly in swimming
pools every year.
And there's no reason for that.
Mostly, it's because people just
haven't taken the precautions.
They don't understand the
dangers of a swimming pool.
And the babies are not prepared
for any type of situation
that involves the water at all.
These guys are all going
through swimming lessons,
infant swimming lessons,
safety and survival
all around the country.
I tagged along, at first,
just to explore the idea,
to see if I could do
something with it.
I shot a story for
"New York Times
Magazine" called "Little Nemos".
That was fun.
And then, we decided,
let's make a book about it.
Don't know if the
book will sell.
Don't really care.
But if we can get the
message out there.
Some of the media
outlets we've been
working with for
water safety for pets,
they're also onboard with this.
So we can at least
get the message out
there about the dangers of
swimming pools and preparing
our human children also for
potential situations like this.
But these guys are fun.
I had a lot of fun
with these babies.
Photographed 750, between
four months and 13 months,
all around the country.
Emphasis on California,
Arizona, Texas, and Florida
with the most swimming pools.
And just had a really good time.
But at the end of
the day, I wasn't
trying to bring any
of them home with me.
Nope.
[LAUGHTER]
SETH CASTEEL: Maybe
one day I'll be a dad.
I really have no idea.
But I'm really proud
of this project.
It will be published
in a few months.
And I hope that it makes
a difference, at least,
a little bit for the situation
right now with children.
And then, we have not
a lot going on here.
Who can tell me what that is?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SETH CASTEEL: Yeah.
Somebody said a dog yesterday.
I'm like, that's the longest
dog nails I've ever seen.
So I have done some work with
some exotic animals underwater.
This little clown right here.
Who can tell me what that is?
AUDIENCE: Otter.
SETH CASTEEL: Wait,
somebody said otter.
Somebody said seal.
Anybody else?
AUDIENCE: Walrus?
AUDIENCE: Sea lion.
SETH CASTEEL: Sea
lion, there it is.
Otter?
Who said that's an otter?
That's way off.
[LAUGHTER]
SETH CASTEEL: [LAUGHS]
That's way off.
That's a California
sea lion named Kai.
And, real quick, I
am working on a book
called "Underwater Creatures".
Whether it becomes a
book, I don't know.
I might have to self-publish it.
It's expensive to make it.
My publisher may or may
not actually want to do it.
But it would be to create some
really interesting and joyful
images of different types
of animals underwater, some
of which were not used to
seeing like orangutans, parrots,
foxes, all kinds of stuff
you wouldn't normally
see underwater.
Would love to make the book.
I think we can also
bring awareness
about all the other
species of animals.
I mean, hey, we got to be
responsible for dogs, and cats,
and human children.
But what about all
the other animals too.
I love animals.
Would love to try to make
a difference for some
of these different species.
A lot of important issues
around each species.
And would love to make the book.
It's a tough challenge, though,
working with wild animals
either in captivity
or in the wild.
It's a very passionate topic.
And without getting
into too much,
as a photographer working
with an animal in the wild,
some people are going
to be upset about that.
If you work with
them in captivity,
some people are going
to upset about too.
I worked with bears in Alaska
for the "New York Times".
They sent me in to
Cooper Landing, Alaska
to document the migration and
spawning of sockeye salmon.
Really cool assignment.
Jumped in the 37 degree
river so excited.
Didn't bring my dry suit.
That would have a good idea.
But did document the salmon.
Along came some bears.
They strolled through.
Did some pictures.
Ended up being reasonably close
to the bears, not by choice.
It just happened.
They wanted the fish.
I was near the fish.
So some people got
upset with me for that.
Because I was just there.
And the bears came along.
I mean, it happens
every day in Alaska.
I mean, it's like we're
on their territory.
And it just happened.
And it's for "The
New York Times".
It's a great piece
about sockeye salmon,
about the conditions that
they're facing right now,
and all the issues.
But people were
upset about that.
I got some death
threats for that.
Oh, yeah.
And that's not everybody.
But it is a hot topic.
It's enough where it bothers me.
And I'm like, did I
do something wrong?
Alternatively, this sea lion
was actually injured by humans
to the point where it could not
live, in the wild, on its own.
So it lives in a
sanctuary in California.
It has the best quality
of life it possibly can.
His name is Kai.
And now he's sort of an
ambassador for sea lions
which is terrific.
I did a photo shoot, for
Kai, to raise awareness
about this sea lion
situation in California
with stranded sea lion pups.
Really, really a big
deal to raise money.
I thought, it's a home run idea.
Posted some shots.
People wanted to kill me.
Death threats.
And I'm like, don't kill me.
I'm trying to do
something good here.
So it's a very tough thing.
I'd like to be able
to make the book,
feature 70 or 80 different
types of animals.
But as you can tell,
I'd like to live.
[LAUGHTER]
SETH CASTEEL: Life
is pretty good.
So I don't know.
We'll see.
But domestic dogs,
domestic cats, people
aren't, I could take
pictures of them.
And it's OK.
But when you start photographing
other types of animals,
in any situation, people
start to ask the question,
should you be doing that?
So I don't know.
But I do look forward to
making that book if I can.
I would be very
excited to make it.
I think it would be fantastic.
And I think it
would be a book that
will make a difference for a
lot of animals out there too.
Anybody have any questions?
MARTHA BISHOP: Martha Bishop.
And are you looking to do
more things than just books?
I see this like being
a TV show or something.
Maybe like going
to people's houses,
and filming that, the
people and their dog.
It's always ends up about
the people and their stories
rather than the dogs.
But to be totally fair, you'd be
brilliant for it, like the "E!
Entertainment" show.
And then, one celebrity
person or something like that.
SETH CASTEEL: Over
the last couple years
there's been some possibilities.
I appeared on a couple of TV
shows, reality TV shows, some
of which were good, Some
of which were questionable.
I appeared on a show
called "Duck Dynasty".
And I didn't know what
it was at the time.
I went on the show.
It turned out to
be this big show.
And overall, it was possible.
But I don't know.
Weird people.
I've had to move away from
"Duck Dynasty" for a while.
Because of all the
controversy and everything,
I just stay out.
But I don't know.
Maybe one day I do a TV show.
I probably rather not do it.
I like my privacy.
People know about my pictures.
Something like a billion people
saw "Underwater Puppies" images
in the last three weeks.
A billion people.
One sixth of the
world population
looking at my images.
That's crazy.
I could walk down the
street, nobody knows me.
I can go shopping.
I can do whatever and
I don't get bothered.
I don't have people
showing up at my house.
And, I guess, if
you had a TV show,
I don't know what it's like
to be famous person, an actor,
or a singer, or something.
But it's got to be
a hassle, I think.
So I think my life is
pretty fun right now.
And I get to just do my thing.
My images can be popular.
I can just be the guy on the
sidelines or behind-the-scenes.
But there are some other
plans, potentially,
for "Underwater
Dogs" in the future.
And I think that I'll make
as many books as I can.
But there's some other
things that we're
working on that may
come to fruition.
So, yeah.
Anybody else?
All righty.
Well, I will be
signing some books
if you'd like me
to sign your book.
It's an extra $100.
[LAUGHTER]
SETH CASTEEL:
Accepting cash only.
Just kidding.
But happy to answer anymore
questions or sign your book.
Thanks for coming.
And thanks for loving dogs
as much as they love us.
[APPLAUSE]